[تصفيق]
ظهر رئيس البيرو بيدروكسبيو الذي اطاح به
البرلمان وتم اعتقاله لاول مره وهو يجيب
على اسئله القاضي عبر تقنيه الفيديو
ويواجه كاستريو تهمه التامر والتمرد بعد
ان حاول حل البرلمان والحكم بمراسم فاطاح
به ب مراسيم فاطاح به البرلمان وشهدت
سعيده مدن بيروفيه مظاهرات تطالب بتنظيم
انتخابات مبكرا وممدده بالاطاحه بكاسيو
وقالت الرئيسه الجديده للقروب دينا
بوليارتي التي كانت تشغل منصب نائب الرئيس
انها ستفكر في امكانيه تنظيم انتخابات
مؤكده انها دفع حاليا هو اعادته توجيه
البلاد وتوحيدها
من ليما عاصمه البيرو معنا مراسل الجزيره
حسان مسعود حسان في ضوئي كل هذه التطورات
كيف تبدو الاوضاع في البلاد
تحديدا هنا في العاصمه البيروفيه لما تشهد
احتجاجات واسعه من قبل مؤيدين الرئيس
المعزول بيدرو كاسيو هنا وسط هذه العاصمه
كما تشاهدون خلفي همم يحتشدوا مؤيدوه
الرئيس المعزول كاسيو الرافدين
لعزله وايضا محاكمته بتهمه الفساد وكذلك
بيتها من محاوله تنظيم انقلاب يتجمعون في
هذا المكان
ويرفعون عدد من
مطالب ابرز هذه المطالب هي همم خروج
الرئيس المعزول من السجن وحل البرلمان
وصياغه برلمان او عفو ان صياغه دستور جديد
للبلاد لهذا الدستور الذي يعتبره مؤيدوه
كاسيه هو سبب الاساسي في الازمات السياسيه
هذه الاسماء
ادت همم الى همم
تبديل البرولي سته رؤساء خلال الاربع
سنوات الماضيه فقط منذ عام 2018 وحتى
اليوم كان اخر الرؤساء هي الرئيسه الاولى
السيده لبيرو دينا التي تحكم البلاد الان
والتي كانت قد اكدت انها ستحكم البلاد
لباقيه الفتره التي كان يحكمها وهي حتى
عام 2026 الا انها الان تتحدث عن احتمالي
همم قيامها بانتخابات الرئاسيه جديده وهذه
الانتخابات يريد مؤيدوه كاسيو ان يكون هو
احد المرشحين لها في حال اقامتها لانهم
يرون انه لاحاق بهذه الرئاسه همم هذه
الاوضاع اتت بعد قيام الرئيس المعزول
تدرسيه بعدد من الاجراءات من بينها همم
امره بحلق البرلمان واقامه حكومه
مائيه الحكومه طوارئ وفردي حاله الطوارئ
الا ان الجيش والشرطه وكذلك البرلمان
ونائبه الرئيس رفض او رفضوا هذه الاجراءات
واعتبروها انقلابا وهو الذي ادى بسجنه هذه
هي الاوضاع همم على ارض الواقع هنا حاليا
شكرا جزيلا لك حسن مسعود مراسيلنا من ليما
عاصمه بيرو